this is a complete red herring if your
bank account was because probably
wouldn't be a recording yeah this is a
complete red herring what's happening is
that there are international rules on
money laundering and whether whether we
have an inquiry into them or whether you
have a bank account that you with a bank
that you don't like those rules won't
change those rules are there to protect
us and to protect shareholders of banks
against people who end up money
laundering no politically exposed people
there's a lot of them there's two around
this table
um there's a lot of them Banks must
assure themselves that their sources of
fund and wealth are real
so we don't know what the situation is
with with farage but one of the things
banks have to do is they have to take
account of what the news flow is around
that person though rightly or wrongly a
labor-back venture accused Nigel farage
of taking half a million pounds from the
Russian government whether that's faraj
denies it whether it's true or not the
bank has to take account of it and it
just has to say well are we running a
risk that we don't want to run and
that's really all that's going on
probably the same thing with you you um
well so how's that happening with me we
don't we don't know I don't know your
personal case so you just said it's
probably happening with me but yeah but
the back yeah they're taking a principal
decision about the risks you have no
idea I do not I do because I understand
banking regulations it's there in black
and white they have to follow their own
regulation this is such an interesting
transformation that's happened to people
like you on the left people like me the
left used to be about protecting the
ordinary person from Big corporations
and big government and all of this stuff
that's what you used to believe in and
here you are you're sitting and
defending a banking corporation no idea
why they made it I'm defending
International banking regulation and law
well it's a great cause that is there to
protect you and me from scammers and
money I can just tell you I don't feel
very protected right now let's let's
hear well let's hear from our
politically exposed persons but I think
the important Point here is that this
isn't just happening to the so-called
exposed people you made the point this
is happening to a lot of people on very
low incomes and that's one of the points
I've been Kim to emphasize throughout
this whole thing my podcast has a
million subscribers across different
platform I can go out and get attention
for this in the media Circle Nigel
farage if you're someone who earns 20
grand and you've said the wrong thing
somewhere that someone didn't like and
they closed your account what are you
going to do this is what point I was
making but it's the point I'm making yep
with respected to what I said the point
I'm making is that there are people on
low income so trying to get access to
financial services yes is really hard
I'd like to see the banks in a little
bit more than than that on that that's
where he comes back to what Kia salma's
been saying about access to all kinds of
services for people on Lower incomes
fine my point is I think it's very
unwise and short term is for people to
say well as long as it's happening to
Nigel farage this is okay and I would
remind you whatever you personally may
feel about Nigel farage I voted remain
in the brexit referendum Nigel farage
represent a hell of a lot of people in
this country and he represents
so many people love him that he's never
single he's never representing a hell of
a lot more people than you but at least
my point is this is not about some whack
it wacko on the far end of the political
Spectrum having their bank account
closed this to someone who has a
mainstream view in this country and this
is completely unacceptable to be
happening to someone is there a problem
though that it took a public figure like
Nigel farage making a who heart about
this for it to kind of get any attention
the irony of this is quite something
literally 10 days ago we changed the law
and it's going through Parliament now so
actually